you les potes j'espère que ça va bien il
ya un an j'ai fait un tweet hilarant sur
les taux de bague
bonjour à tous un petit mot sur l'état
de bague voilà après quelques années ça
y est je pense qu'on peut arrêter la
production
on a tous de quoi faire bonne journée
cyrus si si c'est un peu marrant mais
derrière ce tweet se cache une réalité
la réalité c'est que en voulant réduire
l'usagé de sacs plastiques on a produit
beaucoup beaucoup trop de vagues
et vous me direz oui mais un seul bac
c'est mieux pour l'environnement
accédera bah oui et non en fait oui
parce que ça se dégrade beaucoup moins
nature et non parce que l'impact d'un
seul taux de bagues équivaut à celui de
150 sacs plastiques d'après une étude
danoise qui nous dit qu'en prenant
compte de tous les stades donc de
production distribution usages et
devenir final les sacs en coton sont de
loin les plus polluants ça donne un
petit peu envie de s'étouffer avec un
taux de bague
bon j'ai appris ça je ne se posait la
question de l'efficacité de mes gestes
écologiques
à quoi ça sert de se prendre la tête si
en fait c'est sur les mauvaises choses
cette vidéo est d'ailleurs faite en
partenariat avec greenpeace parce que je
voulais vous parler d'un projet qu'on a
fait ensemble un projet que je trouve
vraiment chouette on l'a fait sur leur
chaîne youtube et leur compte instagram
ça s'appelle science et fiction je vous
mets des liens dans la description et je
vous en reparle en fin de vidéo
alors comment un taux de bague peut
faire pire qu'un sac plastique comment
il peut être plus polluants et dégrader
encore plus l'environnement est en fait
ce dont on parle là c'est les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre alors c'est
principalement du co2 mais envoie y en a
d'autres dont on parle moins mais qui
sont quand même hyper important du coup
on parle en co2 eux donc équivalent co2
comme ça on a une seule métriques ok
alors pourquoi c'est important en gros
et bien parce que plus on n'en rejette
et plus s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère
et réchauffe la terre si on regarde ce
graphique où chaque arrêt représente un
mois depuis 1900 et que sa couleur or
représente son écart de température par
rapport à la moyenne
on réalise que la température a quand
même tendance à bien augmenter là on est
actuellement à 1,2 degré de
réchauffement et pendant les accords de
paris en 2015 les pays se sont engagés à
ne pas dépasser 2 degrés parce que le
risque après c'est l'emballement à la
fonte de la banquise par exemple qui
renvoie quand même une grosse partie des
rayons lumineux du soleil et puis plein
d'autres éléments je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail là maintenant mais en
gros il faut absolument baisser
les émissions de co2 et les autres gaz
si on va vivre comme dans mad max très
très stylée pour un film à vivre dans la
vraie vie c'est pas mon projet perso et
je parle des émissions de co2 sur notre
territoire mais aussi celles dont on est
responsable ailleurs à cause de ce qu'on
consomme en gros je parle de notre
empreinte carbone mais pour voir la
bessée cette empreinte carbone il faut
la comprendre
alors je suis plutôt du genre à ne pas
vouloir culpabiliser les gens mais
plutôt secoué les entreprises et les
gouvernements
cette vidéo j'ai pas du tout envie que
ce soit une énième vidéo genre on va y
arriver ensemble c'est maintenant qu'il
faut agir non voilà je suis pas votre
père si vous voulez faire trois fois le
tour du monde en avion et jetez vos
déchets par la fenêtre
allez-y je vous recommande pas quand
même de jeter les déchets par la fenêtre
de l'avion parce qu'en fait va y avoir
un appel d'air et vous risquez d'être
aspiré par le hublot enfin vraiment très
mauvaise idée si voulez jeter des
déchets par la fenêtre tout fait de leur
voiture bref en tout cas je suis à votre
père mais je trouve ça important de
savoir dans notre quotidien
qu'est-ce qui émet du co2 et à quel
point est donc voir à quel point on a un
comportement qui est écologique ou qui
ne l'est pas parce que ça nous est déjà
arrivé en soirée qu'on nous reproche un
truc qui n'est pas écologique genre moi
on m'a déjà reproché en soirée par
exemple d'utiliser du sopalin chez moi
du sopalin au lieu d'avoir des services
réutilisables en fait ce que je trouve
un petit peu idiot parce que c'est
dérisoire par rapport à plein d'autres
trucs que je fais comme par exemple le
fait d'être végétarien est ce que je
suis en train de répondre en vidéo à
quelqu'un qui n'entendra pas ce message
et que j'ai pas eu le courage de
confronter en soirée peut-être peut-être
alors les amis
rentrons dans cette magnifique échelle
qui est l'échelle du co2 l'échelle de
l'empreinte carbone parce que j'ai envie
de comparer plusieurs éléments afin de
nous rendre compte en fait alors j'ai
voulu commencer par un hommage à mes
parents qui pendant des années m'ont
demandé d'éteindre la lumière de la
salle de bains voilà alors pour ce
premier exemple je vous donnais mon
calcul comme ça vous pouvez le
reproduire chez vous pour plein de
choses et c est de toute manière pour
tous les éléments je mettrai des sources
en descriptions donc j'ai pris une
ampoule à led au secours au secours à
l'aide à l'aide
je suis désolé j'ai pris une ampoule à
led
c'est les plus fréquentes voilà et non
pouladi watts et imaginons qu'elle soit
allumé tout le temps tous les jours sauf
la nuit en gros bien ça fait 10 watts x
16 heures x 365 jours ça fait cinquante
huit mille 400 watts heure donc 58
kilowattheures en 2010 est en france un
kilowatt heure c'était environ 0 avec mu
0 74 kg de co2 donc pour l'ampoulé dans
la salle de bain ça fait 4 kg de co2
vous noterez du coup l'importance de la
provenance de l'électricité je précise
que ce chiffre est bien plus élevée dans
d'autres pays mais dans tous les cas ça
reste un coût non nul
ok continuons 4 kg de co2 eux à quoi ça
correspond et bien pour donner un
élément de comparaison faire 10 km en
voiture à essence
ces deux kilos de co2 donc faire 20 km
c'est à dire en gros la distance entre
paris et son aéroport le plus proche
orly ces quatre kilos de co2 donc paris
à l'aéroport orly en voiture une fois
c'est votre lumière de salle de bain
toute l'année donc là on se rend compte
que la voiture c'est énorme si par
exemple pour aller au boulot ou je ne
sais quoi vous faites 10 km de voiture
tous les jours ses 730 kilos de co2
pour vous donner une idée chauffer son
logement sur une année en ordre de
grandeur
c'est une tonne de co2 ce qui a une
grosse empreinte aussi c'est
l'alimentation
si vous mangez pendant un an un régime
normal ces 2,6 tonnes de co2 par contre
si vous êtes végétarien
pendant cette même année c'est 1,4 tonne
de co2
c'est presque deux fois moins et si vous
faites un aller retour en avion à los
angeles
vous en avez pour 4,5 tonnes de co2 par
personne
waouh on peut s'arrêter un moment dessus
s'il vous plaît donc là c'est évidemment
en prenant en compte et ses acquis et
plein de gens dans l'avion enfin c'est
le vrai calcul quoi certains vols long
courrier suivant vous a laissé de 3 à 5
ans de végétarisme
c'est énorme c'est énorme mais je vais
pas vous mentir la première réaction
quand on apprend ça c'est dire ok mon
bas en fait
en fait ça rien quoi sert à rien de
faire des efforts je fais je prenne
l'avion une fois et à quoi ça sert en
tout cas c'était ma première réaction
et pourtant je suis toujours obligé de
rien pourquoi déjà parce que c'est pas
parce que je fais un truc de pas bien
que je dois jeter toutes les bonnes
actions à la poubelle ce serait une
forme
je sais pas de facilités quoi une sorte
de flemme une sorte de déni enfin voila
c'est on peut quand même faire la part
des choses et ensuite pourquoi je lâche
pas mes efforts tout simplement parce
qu'on n'a pas le choix en fait on est
obligé de baisser nos émissions de
carbone notamment si on veut respecter
les accords de paris comme dit plus haut
alors est-ce que tout repose sur des
individus comme vous et moi
évidemment non et l'étude de carbone 4
qui est un cabinet de conseil
indépendant sur le carbone qui nous dit
que si on prend les éco-gestes classique
c'est à dire faire du vélo consommer
local prendre - l'avion manger moins de
viande et c'est donc ce qu'ils ont
appelé un changement réaliste de
comportement eh ben on arriverait à
baisser notre empreinte individuelle de
10 % et si on rajoute à ça des
investissements là aussi considéré comme
réaliste c'est à dire des
investissements pour l'isolation
thermique ou le changement de la
chaudière ce genre de choses on arrive
de nouveau à faire baisser notre
empreinte de 10%
donc ça fait 20 % tous je précise que
dans le modèle héroïque ou là tout le
monde et pg tard et un ans prend plus
l'avion etc
on baisse notre empreinte individuel de
45%
mais restons sur le réaliste puisque
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est le plus
réaliste pour respecter les accords de
paris faut qu'on ait une baisse
individuel de 80% donc c'est 20% sur les
80 % bah je trouve ça intéressant parce
qu'en fait c'est un quart piles et un
quart ce qui me plaît là dedans c'est
que bah c'est pas suffisant
clairement mais c'est assez important
pour qu'on puisse pas s'en passer en
fait rien que le fait d'être végétarien
ça représente à lui tout seul 10% de la
baisse totale donc ça doit pas être
décourageant au contraire on se rend
compte qu avec plein de petites choses
mises ensemble on peut faire baisser de
20%
le total de notre empreinte individuel
et pour le reste il faut faire pression
sur le collectif mais je trouvais ça
important de vous partager quelques
ordres de grandeur en fait parce que la
clé de ce combat comme dans beaucoup de
combats d'air c'est l'information
si on est bien informé on va pouvoir
prendre les bonnes décisions et arrêter
de produire par exemple des milliers de
bach quoi fret écrit tabak
par exemple en faisant cette vidéo je me
suis rendu compte d'un truc que je
pouvais faire
hyper simplement et qui réduirait
drastiquement mon empreinte carbone
c'est juste arrêter de me brosser les
dents
c'est totalement faux non c'est juste je
me suis rendu compte que je pouvais
juste changé mon fournisseur
d'électricité ou changer ma banque passé
vers une banque plus verte
voilà c'est quelque chose qui prend
juste
quelques heures en termes
d'administratifs et qui ensuite un
impact sur des années mon père habite à
los angeles
je veux pas arrêter d'aller à los
angeles par contre je te dis allez moins
souvent et quand je vais y aller rester
plus longtemps
c'est juste prendre des décisions de bon
sens en fait avec les bonnes
informations
par exemple il ya deux ans j'étais
invité à une convention qui se passait à
nice et ils m'ont invité en avion eh ben
je pense que si ça se faisait
aujourd'hui je leur dirais ok en fait
j'ai pas besoin de venir en avion je
prendrai un train mettez moi un peu plus
tôt voilà comme ça j'ai le temps
d'arriver et moi je vais travailler
pendant le train et c'est cool ça ne
mange pas c'est à chacun d'être à l'aise
avec ses engagements en fait c'est comme
un régime alimentaire
si vous vous restreignez trop au bout
d'un moment vous allez craquer ensuite
vous allez surconsommer c'est pas ça le
but et connaître les ordres de grandeur
ça aide et dernière chose je vous ai pas
mal parlé d'utilisation mais c'est
intéressant d'avoir les ordres de
grandeurs liés à l'achat en fait je
m'explique ma télé par exemple si je la
regarde deux heures par jour tous les
jours pendant un an
j'adorerais avoir le temps de le
regarder ma télé deux heures par jour
pour l'anecdote depuis donc ma vie des
emménagements obstacle est sorti je ne
vais pas utiliser une seule fois george
est rien regarder dessus sérieusement et
ça fait genre un mois un mois et demi
c'est une parenthèse c'est juste pour
vous expliquer à quel point ma vie
m'agace parfois bref si je regarde deux
heures par jour tous les jours pendant
un an
ces huit kilos de co2 en revanche
l'action de l'acheter c'est 343 kilos de
co2 c'est à dire à peu près autant que
la regarder deux heures par jour tous
les jours pendant 43 ans
en gros voilà ce que ça donne une bonne
idée de l'impact de l'achat par rapport
à l'utilisation
c'est à cause de toutes les matières
premières quêtes dans des fois il ya des
minerais rares et c est encore là on est
juste sur de l'écologie on parle même
pas de géopolitique et c'est pareil pour
la voiture à essence je vous disais tout
à l'heure que
10 km de voiture tous les jours pendant
un an c'était 730 kilos de co2 et bain
juste l'action de l'acheter ces 3 7
tonnes de co2
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça je vous ai
pas parlé de voitures électriques tout à
l'heure dans les usages parce que ça
pouvait être trompeur en fait
effectivement la voiture électrique et
consomment beaucoup beaucoup moins à l'
usage mais à l'achat l'empreinte carbone
elle est plus forte puisqu'elle est de
6,6 tonnes de co2
c'est à dire presque le double ce qui
fait que par exemple sur 150 km quand on
compare tout c'est à dire l'achat plus
la consommation pour la voiture à
essence on est autour de 22 tonnes de
co2 et pour la voiture électrique on est
autour de 9 tonnes de co2
c'est moins c'est sûr mais on aurait pu
penser que la différence était beaucoup
plus grande et en fait non et c'est
pareil pour pas mal d'éléments du
quotidien et pas que dans le multimédia
alors par exemple si je devais racheter
ma garde-robe de 50 kg et ben c'est une
tonne de co2
alors quand on sait qu'une perceuse sert
en moyenne 12 minutes on se rend compte
qu'une des clés du combat c'était pas
forcément de faire plus c'est à dire
acheter une voiture électrique de dengue
ou une super gourde avec plastique sans
bpa
1 c'est peut-être juste de faire - en
fait pour l'anecdote au niveau du
sopalin j'ai pas trouvé de sources
fiables
j'ai trouvé plusieurs sources pas fiable
qui tombait tout sur à peu près 15
grammes de co2 par rouleau donc avec ma
consommation
c'est en gros 2 kg de co2 par an donc
oui effectivement c'est dérisoire mais
en même temps qu'est ce que ça me coûte
de le remplacer par des tensions qui
traîne un vieux t-shirt les services
réutilisables pas grand chose quoi pas
faire plus mais faire moins cette vidéo
c'est aussi pour parler d'un projet
qu'on a sorti avec l'inpi ce qu'ils
partent du postulat suivant pour avoir
une réflexion sur le futur et trouver
des innovations qui vont nous permettre
de faire face aux défis de demain
eh bien il faut d'abord pouvoir
l'imaginer c'est pour ça qu'on a créé
des discussions entre des personnes du
monde académique et des personnes du
monde de la fiction ou la création qui
sont habitués à nous raconter des
histoires donc ça s'appelle science et
fiction on en a fait 3 il y en a un sur
l'habitat avec un architecte et notre is
de science-fiction 1 sur le voyage avec
une anthropologue est une poétesse et un
dernier sur l'alimentation avec un
agronome et un chef triplement étoilé et
son restaurant a gagné le prix
meilleur restaurant du monde voilà en
toute simplicité
d'ailleurs je me demande dans quelle
catégorie je pourrais gagner un jour un
truc genre meilleurs du monde
enfin moi je trouve ça fou du monde faut
vraiment que je trouve un truc niche
quoi bref j'ai appris plein de choses ça
a déconstruit plein d'idées reçues que
j'avais et du coup je vous les
recommande chaudement évidemment tous
les liens sont la description dernière
chose dans cette vidéo je me suis
concentré sur le co2 eux on aurait pu
parler de plein de choses qu'on a peu
parlé de la biodiversité on aurait pu
parler des océans de la pollution des
sols
malheureusement il ya trop de choses des
amis donc j'ai préféré me concentrer sur
un élément pour ne pas tout mélanger
j'espère en tout cas ce que vous a plu
et que surtout ça vous sera utile love
peace ciao